So we already talked about the visibly sweaty
and orange, Donald Trump, a black bragging
to a Colorado Springs crowd about his followers
essentially being cultists.
I want to take a few minutes now to mention
more generally that at that same rally in
Colorado Springs and at the following one
that he did in Las Vegas, Nevada, Donald Trump
looked and sounded more unwell than we've
seen in a really long time.
And the things he was saying were concerning
the way he looked was concerning and the way
he sounded was concerning.
And people are noticing the international
business times reported Trump reportedly looks
bad at Vegas rally POTUS suffering from mental,
physical decline.
A number of other articles asked essentially
the same questions.
Let's look at some examples from two events.
Again, it's the Colorado Springs rally and
then a Las Vegas rally.
Trump again, visibly sweaty, very red upper
Trump and Colorado Springs downer.
Trump in Las Vegas.
Uh, maybe Trump arriving sort of late East
coast time for the Colorado Springs rally.
Maybe needed a little something to get them
going for that one.
Wouldn't be surprising if he was getting himself
a boost with something.
Check out Trump, unable to read his teleprompter
in the context, uh, that, uh, the speech is
written slurring about the Rocky mountains,
making no syntactical sense here.
Beautiful place beneath the majestic peaks.
That's true of the Rocky mountains with thousands
of terrific, hardworking, great American Patriots.
Trump then started wildly reading totally
out of context numbers with no reasonable
inflection where you can even understand what
on earth this guy is talking about.
Nice one.
Look at this.
Trump 70% next one is 18% next one is seven,
four, three, three, three, two, one, one,
one didn't do well in the debate.
See, have fake news.
Then Trump's slurring and attacking someone.
Not exactly sure who
is this [inaudible]
feels good.
[inaudible]
she's a third rate journalist.
Let's go.
We're standing up in defense of our constitution
and then Trump started mixing up conflicting
conspiracy theories, which was really weird.
Try to understand this and look at how he
takes like two or three words from different
conspiracy theories
and you know, we're working with a cloud.
We're working with these people that want
to take you out.
They want to change the results.
They got caught spying with st like it is
right.
They got caught spying on our election factors.
Hey, fake news, take your cameras for change
and show them the room and show him
the cloud spying fake news election like it's
completely dissembling in front of our very
eyes.
Then he starts talking about mayor Pete and
I guess now he's referring to mayor Pete as
Buddha touch Buddha touch.
Listen to this.
Alfred E Newman booty tech, little put a touch.
I said, I've had you up to here.
They had little Buddha case leading Donald
Trump in Texas.
These people, but very close or you said it's
too close to call.
This is a poll where booted dead.
So a friend of mine from Texas, a big powerful,
strong guy, real Texas.
He's got the cowboy hat.
I'd love to wear that hat.
I wouldn't have to call buy sob.
I wouldn't need hairspray.
Right.
I'd love those Texas.
That's, I don't know if we'd get away with
it or Washington.
That's why I live, but I love it.
Then Trump really struggling to say the word
statistics
killing you within a very short period of
time.
You're going to see some [inaudible] coming
out on one statisticians.
I got to do it right.
Otherwise they'll say, what throne?
I liked that status sticks.
So this is already bad enough, right?
This is Colorado Springs, but then we go to
Las Vegas and things get even worse.
Trump trying to talk about some health care
plan he was supposedly going to do already,
but then it never happened and he sounds like
a used car salesman.
Notice that Trump in Vegas, this is now downer.
Trump, Trump and Colorado Springs was upper.
Trump read talking quickly.
This is now downer.
Trump talking about, we're going to give you
brand new preexisting.
Now you might be saying there's gotta be some
other word missing there.
Yeah, but Trump's talking about brand new,
preexisting
for Obamacare, but we're going to terminate
it.
We're going to give you your preexisting a
hundred otherwise I won't do it.
We're going to give you brand new, preexisting,
and we're going to have a great healthcare
that's much less expensive.
Then Trump mocks Joe Biden for his stutter.
That's a disability.
It's like mocking someone for having diabetes
and Biden is androgen.
Biden is, everything's anchor cheesy.
And that's what happens when you can't get
the words out.
No, it does.
That's what happens.
Right?
When you can't get the words out, you get
angry, you get angry cause you can't get the
words that might happen to me some day.
Can you imagine if that happened to me, man,
when I'd be in our bad guy.
And then this is the height of megalomania
Trump claims and maybe believes that if a
plane crashed with 700 people on it, media
wouldn't cover it.
But instead they would talk about Donald Trump.
You know, cable was supposed to be obsolete
and now they're doing the highest numbers
they've ever done.
If an airplane goes down with 700 people,
they don't cover it.
If it's not truck related, they don't cover,
it's gotta be Trump or Trump related.
So the plane goes down and it's total devastation.
If the ship down, if the Titanic is the Titanic
equivalent went down, they wouldn't cover
it unless I was on the sucker.
And then of course the capstone, the slurring
begins to take place in Vegas.
Remember Trump was upper Trump and Colorado
Springs.
Trump downer.
Trump in Vegas and downer.
Trump often does the slurring,
ladies and gentlemen introducing president
Alfred E Newman, but she, nobody knows cause
you're all too young.
Nobody knows who Alfred.
It's bad magazine.
It's very bad.
And people around Donald Trump are continuing
to privately sound the alarm and at this rate,
if this continues, the debates are going to
be something else.
It will, it will be like nothing we have ever
seen before.
No matter who the democratic nominee eventually
is.
I, I presume that upper Trump would be better
for the debates than downer Trump.
And so we would expect more of the Trump that
was in Colorado Springs than the Trump that
was in Las Vegas, Nevada.
Let me know what
you think.
I don't know what to make of
it at this point